everybody's gamescom 2014 Sean McGinnis
and Andy Bauman here we've just played a
bit of fable legends over at the xbox
booth and Andy walking out of that demo
there's one of those awkward moments
where I was like yeah and you were like
oh I was like so did you like that so
clearly we're in a state of disagreement
about fable legends I want to know what
was it about that game it kind of rubbed
you the wrong way okay good question
i'll preface it by saying the guy said
the character I was playing was very
early and so maybe they just hadn't
ironed out some of the you know my
ability of it especially but i was
playing healer and I had to stay alive
and heal you because you were the tank I
was attending the only way I could do
that was whole energy from enemies and
then shoot it at you in tix of a hundred
so you're helpful go it was really like
stilted right I feel like there wasn't
that many enemies to pull from and the
pull rate was really slow so you did not
like you had much of an effete and I was
like shooting at you and there's like
that was my role yeah I didn't feel like
I had any effect really and if I think
there's one time when everybody was the
dead basically someone guy except me and
then you revived me yep and i was and i
had a special ability where I
immediately sacrificed myself and then
revived everybody else which that was
cool very cool and I did that but other
than that I felt like I was just kind of
a weird game so okay so obviously me
playing is the tank I could've had the
opposite experience good because I felt
like I had like a really good impact on
the world fable legends the presentation
yeah like I was actually I was really
impressed with the way that game looks
and feels because I mean animation is so
much a part of like how responsive a
game is so like the tank when I swing
that sword I want to look at those
little goblin archers things and have to
really respond to the weight of the
impact and I felt like they did okay and
so just like the sense of movement and
me use my shield with my shield bash and
doing my sword swipes as the tank you
know that sense of immediate seeing that
sense of impact it felt really good yeah
I mean I was surprisingly enjoying it
well I enjoyed the concept which we can
really touched on it's 41 so yeah all
right fable legends for b1 the for our
class based heroes the one is the
villain who's playing the game from a
tow brand perspective he's kind of the
dungeon master Dungeon Keeper almost
like he does things like if you are
running through a little choke point he
can shoot able stresses to separate one
hero from the others and I couldn't I
had no ability to lower the fence
whereas you could I can actuate was your
sword so that's kind of a class-based
disadvantage so they I was isolated as
the healer that would be bad news for
you well I mean at this point it seems
like there's probably one big takeaway
here which is fable legends still have
some balancing issues to work out if you
happen to be on the good side of that
balancing issue you're gonna have a
great time with it on ND side maybe not
so much but hopefully they get that
figured out because there's definitely
some stuff about that game that I think
both of us enjoyed so you know say to it
I guess stay tuned we'll find out more
down the line
you